dans cette ville est inerte cette foule
criardes si étonnamment passé à côté de
son cri de son sens sans inquiétude
à côté de son vrai cri le seul qu'on ait
voulu l'entendre crier parce qu'on le
sent siens lui seul parce qu'on le sent
habité en elle dans quelques ruches
profond d'ombré et d'orgueil dans cette
ville inerte
cette foule à côté de son cri de 20 de
misère de révolte de haine
cette foule si étrangement bavarder
muette dans cette ville inerte
cette foule désolé sous le soleil ne
participant à rien de ce qu'ils
s'expriment s'affirme se libère au grand
jour de cette terre sienne ni à
l'impératrice joséphine des français
rêvant très haut au-dessus de la
négraille ni aux libérateurs figée dans
sa libération de pierre blanchi au bout
du petit m'adore
cette ville inerte et c'est au delà de
peur tapis dans les ravins de peur juché
dans les arbres de peur creusé dans le
sol de peur en dérive dans le ciel
qu'y puis-je
il faut bien commencer comment c'est
quoi la seule chose qui vaille la peine
de commencer la fin du monde
parbleu
sachez le bien accommodée vous de moi je
ne m'accommode pas de fous que 200 dans
ma mémoire dans ma mémoire sont des
lacunes elles sont couvertes de tête de
mort elles ne sont pas couvertes de
nénuphars dans ma mémoire sont des
lacunes sur leurs rives ne sont pas
étendus des bagnes de femmes ma mémoire
est entouré de 100 ma mémoire à sa
ceinture de ghadames et au milieu de
tout ça je dis hourra mon grand père
meurt jeudi hourra la vieille négritude
progressivement ce qu'adam et reese
il n'ya pas dire c'était un bon
les blancs disent que c'était un bon
vrai bon le bon à son
maître
je dis ouah c'est accents très bon
la misère regard des blessés poitrine et
d'eau et on avait fourré dans sa pauvre
cervelle d'une fatalité peser sur lui
qui n'avait pas puissant sur son propre
destin qu'un seigneur méchant avaient de
toute éternité écrit des lois
d'interdiction à sa nature belle vienne
et d'être le bon de croire
honnêtement à son intimité sans
curiosité perverse de vérifier jamais
les hiéroglyphes fatidique
c'était un très bon jeudi cours à
la vieille négritude progressivement ce
cade averys l'horizon se défait recul et
s'élargit le négrier craque de toutes
parts son ventre ce qu'on veut c'est
résonne la négraille aux senteurs
d'oignons frits retrouve dans son sang
répandu le goût amer de la liberté elle
est debout la négraille la négraille à 6
inattendument debout debout dans la cale
debout dans les caps il debout sur le
pont de boue dans le vent debout sous le
soleil de loups dans le sang debout et
libre debout et non point pauvre folle
de sa liberté
debout et libre inutile d'apitoyer pour
nous l'un des sens de vos sourires de
kystes suppure ans parce que nous vous
annonçons vous et votre raison nous nous
réclamons de la démence précoce de la
folie flambante du cannibalisme tenace
quand on la folie qui se souvient la
folie qui hurlent à la folie qui voit la
folie qui se déchaînent assez de ce goût
de cadavres aux fans
nous prenons l'opposition pour
l'imposition que deux et deux font 5 que
la forêt miaule que l'arbre eux tirent
les marrons du feu que le ciel soliste
la barbe et cetera et cetera qui est
quelles sommes nous admirable question
haïsseurs bâtisseurs très fou quand ou
quand surtout car nous voulons tous les
démons ceux d'hier et ceux d'aujourd'hui
ceux du quart quand ces deux là où ceux
de l'interdiction de la prohibition du
marronnage et nous l'avons garde
d'oublier ceux du négriers donc nous
chantant qui puis-je il faut bien
commencer comment c'est quoi
la seule chose qu'il va et la peine de
commencer la fin du monde parbleu
[Musique]
et